>> Charles, I lied.
>> No!
>> I'm so sorry. In fact, it turns out
that there is no tweak that you could do to
these algorithms to make the trifecta, to have all
3of these properties. And, in fact, there is no clustering
algorithm. It is impossible to derive a clustering algorithm
that has these 3 properties. So this is proven by
Kleinberg, and what he showed is that, once you
define these 3 different properties,
richness, scale invariance, and consistency,
they are mutually contradictory in a sense. So, just like we saw
in the example that we went through in the quiz, where we tweak
the algorithm and it gets us one but it loses another, that's
a necessary property. You just can't have all these 3 hold at once.
>> That's pretty surprising coming from Kleinberg, because John is
one of the nicest people I know in machine learning and
theory, and you would think that he would have tried to
find a possibility theorem, not an impossibility theorem. I'm very disappointed.
>> See, he's got a dark
side, is what I'm saying. This is a striking and
maybe even upsetting result, right? It's saying that, if you
actually sit down and say, well, here's what I would
like my clustering algorithm to be, which people hadn't really
done very often, once you've bothered to go do all
that hard work of saying what matters to you and
what doesn't matter to you, it turns out you can't
have what you want. You can't always have what you want.
>> But, can you get what you need?
>> In this particular case,
maybe. It depends if you only need 2 of these. [LAUGH]
>> Well, so how bad is this? So, so, so, I agree, it is, it is
a at least to me, a surprising result that you can't have all 3 of them.
And it's a little disappointing because you'd love
to have an algorithm that does. Because, I
think we agree, all 3 of these properties
makes sense. At least, certainly, independently they do.
>> Right.
>> But just how bad is it? I mean when, when you can't have all
3, can you come close to having all 3? Can you have like 2.9 of them?
[LAUGH]
>> Well, you can definitely have two of
them, because that's what we did in the quiz.
>> hm.
>> Well, it kind of depends on what, you
can reinterpret some of these properties and get, and nearly
satisfy them. And I can point you to Kleinberg's
paper to look into that. But I think I need
to be done with this for now. I just
wantedto give you a flavor of the idea that, one
of the reasons that clustering is hard to pin down
is because when you pin it down, it plays dead.
>> Hm.
>> It's like a, it's like an opossum. When you pin it down, it actually
it turns out that it still doesn't really want to do what you
want it to do. But in practice, what happens is people do clustering
for lots of different reasons. And
they're willing to change their clustering, like,
look at what actually comes out of it, and change their notion of
clustering so that it's more consistent
with what they're trying to achieve. It's
not great to use in this purely automated fashion, where you just hand
it over to the computer and be done with it. But it's still
a really powerful thing to do to get to know your data better.
>> Okay.
I accept that. I feel better now.